the halo universe a rich intricate
tapestry chronicling humanity's
perseverance in the face of near
extinction against universe destroying
technology exploding lovecraftians four
monsters and giant alien cabals of space
scientologists you know normal sci-fi
stuff halo is a universe more interwoven
and complex than perhaps even our real
life i mean the most complex thing i've
ever done is remember my sister's
birthday
but perhaps this complexity is exactly
why halo has always felt like home to me
from the moment i stepped onto
installation zero four i knew that i
needed to know everything there was
about it because it felt so comforting
and welcoming and fresh and new and
exciting and that's why for over the
past 20 years i've
consumed nearly every single piece of
halo media that's ever been made from
reading halo first strike while my
sister blew out her candles on her first
birthday cake to listening to the
episodes of hunt the truth podcast
during my sister's graduation speech
halo has been like family to me and i i
know everything about it
like do i know that the halo first
strike novel once referred to the shiyun
prophets as having insect antenni do i
know the backstory of legendary
sangheili warrior usa exellis
did the iso died act opposed the
creation of the halo erased
do i know my sister's dreams and
aspirations
and it appears that halo infinite which
promises to be the culmination of the
halo universe will finally justify my
years of study and self-isolation it
kind of seems like it but what good is
knowledge if not shared so to prepare
all of you to finish the fight for
realsies this time i'm going to explain
every single piece of halo media and i
mean every single piece of halo media
but don't worry don't worry there's not
that much there's just six main games
and
two spin-off shooters
two rts games
two twin stick shooters as well and a vr
game and
a few films and
some short films on top of that and
20 plus novels and
some graphic novels too after that and
and
a lot of comics and
an audio drama and
a board game don't forget the board game
and an arcade cabinet
okay look it's a little complicated but
don't worry we're gonna keep it simple
we're just gonna make it a nice little
timeline and we're just gonna start at
the beginning which dates all the way
back to
100 000 bc
[Music]
okay so to dive in this we're going to
start with just the games that everyone
has played and then we'll go into
everything in chronological order but i
feel like starting with the games will
make this a little bit more
comprehensible
but the most important thing to remember
with all of this is that we're just here
for the lore
no emotional resonance none of this
character development and stuff like
that we just want information that's
what you're here for that's what you
come to our videos for all the details
none of this emotional drama
hey low combat evolved humanity fights
are losing war against space
scientologists finds an ancient ring
that kills
while everything in the galaxy as well
as the flood and master chief explodes
it because protagonist also in this game
cortana looks like the over sexualized
love child of terminator and waluigi so
there's that as well halo 2 the covenant
attack earth and then find another halo
which they think will make them go clear
so again chief and the sexy arbiter
played by keith david blow it up and
then everyone's upset by the cliffhanger
sir
finishing this fight
one eternity later halo 3 coming to find
the ark which makes halo ring so master
chief
also blows up that yadda yadda covenant
beaten flood beaten master chiefs asleep
in cryogenic sleep for a few years
technically also there's a vr game set
during this time period called halo vr
where you play as a marine preparing for
the big fight in halo 3 and it's
actually a really cool vr experience
that's totally meaningless because you
just play one of the brains that
massachusetts runs over when he takes
off a warthog
halo wars a few years before halo 1 you
play as the spirit of fire crew fighting
a sexy non-keith david arbiter as you
try to stop them from getting a 4-run
fleet halo reach right before halo 1 a
team of noble spartans defends reach
from the covenant but
they all die and fail yeah i mean it's
emotionally resonant but who cares these
guys all die they sucks to be them
spartan assault right after halo 3 my
dream wife sarah palmer finds an ancient
former weapon because what else are you
gonna do in the halo universe and it's
uh it's underwhelming halo spartan
strike the same thing as spartan assault
but no badass future wife so it's even
less awesome halo 4. massachusetts wakes
up this universe general zod with the
didact and he tries to blow up earth
because
of course he does but cortina is dying
from rampancy because too much
information is degrading her ai matrix i
was put into service eight years ago
eight years
ai's deteriorate after seven chief
she's like a person with too much lore
baked into her brain and is trying to
share it with others and she ultimately
fails and dies because of it but in her
final few moments she feels and touches
the master chief for the first time her
first connection to another human in her
last moments of life one moment of
connection with another person gave her
more meaning than endless bounds of
knowledge could have ever done
sorry i don't know what came over me
there back to the plot uh dinect dies
cortana dies hooray halo 4 spartan ops
the amazing sarah palmer fights covenant
radicals for those forerunner macguffins
and also dr halsey is a giant jerk and
betrays everyone halo 5 guardians turns
out cortana is live and evil now and
using guess what engine 4 forerunner
technology because everyone's going to
use that to try and take over the
universe oh also there's some guy named
lok so
cool for him halo wars 2 the spirit fire
crew wakes up on the ark to find it
under control of the banished a covenant
splinter group run by wwe fighter atriox
they fight him another halo gets made dr
anders gets sent off on it and that's
where we're left off with them and then
there's halo infinite right at the end
of our timeline
here
so this is how our timeline looks we got
this ancient history up here that we
have yet to fill in we have halo wars
starting here it goes all the way
through to halo 3 then it comes down
here to halo spartan assault and spartan
strike and goes all the way to halo
infinite down here so let's start
filling this bad boy in
[Music]
the krypton primordium silentium trilogy
okay to be fair starting us off this
trilogy is packed with so much lore i
could literally do its own whole video
on it and believe me i want to let
mickey game spot let me anyways let's
speed through the bare essentials on
these ones
100 000 years ago the foreigners beat
humans in a galactic war and then forced
humans to live in small tribes on earth
which wasn't our homeworld because
surprise humans only fought the war to
escape the flood which were consuming
the galaxy faster than i consumed thai
and media the died act who would later
become the big bad of halo 4 wanted to
turn humanity into ai prometheans and
make shield worlds to protect everyone
from the flood but when he fought other
foreigners to get his way he was locked
away for thousands of years but then
eventually gets woken up and perpetuates
the huge political schism before being
locked away again until halo 4. there's
also some stuff about an eso died act
being created but more importantly the
master builder says nah to shield worlds
and instead tries to create giant halo
rings that destroy all life in the
universe to start the flood after some
political inviting the master builder is
convinced by the dead ex-wife to also
reseed life afterwards so not everything
would be dead circle of life and so on
she also saved some samples of the flood
because i guess she wanted to make sure
the halo games happen presumably then an
ai created by the four owners called
medical bias gets corrupted by the flood
and turns against its creators forcing
the foreigners to activate the final
seven halo rings from the lesser arc
killing all life and then remnants of
humanity and other races are sent out
through portals to repopulate the galaxy
all that makes sense yeah okay oh also
in these books there's a cute little guy
named chakas who is an adorable little
human just filled with kindness and love
so
of course he dies a horrible terrible
death
but his consciousness does get turned
into an uncaring ai robot named 343
guilty sparks so there's that
that's cool it doesn't
doesn't hurt my emotions at all i don't
i don't have emotions i'm just i'm just
i'm just here for information halo
broken circle in 1000 bce the covenant
is formed with the sexy fertile shan
chiyun as their leaders and they put
down a rebellion of the sangheili but
they were just they were just trying
their best man also i realized i should
put dates on this timeline apparently
nothing important happens in this like
100 000 years between these two things
but a crap ton happens in 2552 which
just goes through all the way here just
think of like 25 52 as the 2020 and 2021
of the halo universe
legends the duel in 2142 the arbiter
portrays the covenant and then is killed
it's very sad and also explains why the
arbiter titles only give it to those who
the prophets hate oh and also everyone
just like they're in an anime in this
one the fall of reach boot camp so
technically these comics are the
adaptation of the fall of reach book but
that takes place over numerous years and
the comics like separate that out so i'm
just gonna go by the comics and then put
the book where it ends in the timeline
so in this one dr halsey kidnaps a bunch
of kids and turns them into super
soldiers by injecting them with drugs
killing a bunch of them and then turning
them into child super soldiers so
that's that's great ethics am i right
that i don't i don't hate everything
contact harvest humanity makes first
contact with the covenant and uh decides
to kill everyone because we
probably deserve it
we're all cold
emotionless beings with no hearts or
souls
also there's some alien sex in this one
so
there you go
collateral damage master chief in the
blue team gets sent to get more foreign
tech because that's what we do in this
universe silent storm a master chief
story and surrexus try to team up with
the covenant to kill master chief it
doesn't work out for them halo 4 forward
unto dawn some dude named leisky plays
capture the flag and then gets rescued
from the covenant by the master chief
halo oblivion mass steve and blue team
do some stuff
who cares halo legends homecoming a
spartan named daisy gets sent back to
her home planet during the war has some
flashbacks then dies very poetic and sad
but
no one cares no one
no one ever cares
why do i even care
halo wars genesis
um sorry uh
halo wars genesis uh the early arbiter
is an [ __ ] in the spirit of fire crew
do
something i don't
i don't know i
why am i even doing this these stories
are these tours are too emotional i
don't
i think i need a break
in fact what's coming up uh death for
technology more comics
oh
oh
guys i actually missed a whole game i
forgot about halo fire team raven the
arcade game in fact i've never actually
even played fire team
i wonder
okay so i found a dave and buster's that
is about an hour away from where i live
and it actually has a fire teen raven in
it so we're going there right now let's
do this thing
[Music]
actually i can't legally drive with this
thing on so we're just gonna we're just
gonna just drive normally i'm just gonna
i'm gonna put that over here just it's
gonna be right there yeah that'll be
fine
[Music]
didn't anticipate the target dave and
buster's hybrid there so
that's kind of fun
third floor to fun everyone third third
floor to fun
[Music]
okay where is this guy
i'm here i actually i i actually drove
all the way here look
we have ethan who looks really angry we
got marcus who's uh really into
communications uh we got victor who
definitely does not look 20 and ava who
looks pretty bum in purple uh so we're
going with ava i'm an almost 30 year old
adult about to play a four-player halo
game during the middle of a work day
i live assad
lonely life
and i'm very excited about it
that's the pillar of autumn that's the
face of the game that i like
[Music]
ava and victor are totally a thing
they're totally together
so i'm halfway through this game so far
and one thing i never noticed is
apparently how much the covenant like to
stand in color coordinated waves of four
in a row
[Music]
it's apparently a very tried and true
covenant strategy that i just never
noticed in all the other games
[Music]
we did it we did it we're all gonna make
it out of time
victor can finally make good on their
love
maybe
they're probably fine
you guys that was just so much fun i i i
got to experience like being on halo
again it's been so many years it was
like i got to know the stories of ava
and ethan and victor and marcus and
their team dynamic and it was just it
was just so wonderful and i just wish
that i had got to play with other people
and and share it and and share the
experience of of that again instead of
alone
by myself
it's a co-op game and
i felt kind of meaningless doing it all
by myself you know and that
and i mean
just like that the characters of the
game their story is meaningless too i
mean they all
died on installation zero four i mean
they helped the master chief a little
bit but
no one really remembers their names
just forgotten
lonely
[Music]
it's almost as if their game shouldn't
even go on the board because it didn't
matter
but it mattered to me
you'll never be forgotten fireteam raven
halo legends prototype a marine named
ghost uses a prototype armor to save
civilians against his orders then dies
halo the coal protocol a fairly
inconsequential book about the story of
jacob keys and the sacrifice he has to
make as a military commander caught
between the covenant and the
insurrection is sometimes sacrificing
his men and pointless battle because
humans just couldn't stop by each other
it's truly a heartbreaking
strong character keys gets promoted to
commander and the future arbiter
impresses the prophets tales from space
something has happened nothing happens
halo legends the babysitter smode st's
including dutch as well as a spartan
gets sent on a mission and one of them
turns out to be a pretty girl who
sacrifices herself for them and it's
really sad
halo legends the package master chief
saves dr halsey's life
battleborn four high schoolers watch
their entire family die in a covenant
attack on the planet meridian and escape
with the help of an injured spartan and
everyone just has a boatload of trauma
halo meridian divide three months later
the military thinks it's a smart idea to
send those same exact kids with that
boatload of trauma back to find a
forerunner artifact called a macguffin
on their home planet because we're well
beyond ethics at this point
halo hell jumpers odst dutch and romeo
find foreign technology and they blow it
up because that's all we can do in this
damn series the fall of reach covenant
surprise surprise the master chief and
friends tried to stop the covenant from
finding more forerunner technology get a
new storyline halo oh also the covenant
learns the location of reach halo
bloodline okay this one's kind of cool
we meet the smart and black team and
their ai iona who find a foreigner
outpost trying to build an immunity to
the flood which seems like a much
smarter idea than you know blowing up
all life with the halos but you know
what phone would taking a vaccine be to
letting everyone die
but turns out the monitor in charge of
the vaccine has gone crazy from
isolation which is
too relatable
halo the fall of reach and halo reach
invasion okay so here's where the comic
can book a line and the master chief
fails at saving reach but escapes while
everyone else dies
the flood this book is just the story of
halo 1 but we get the arbiter's point of
view
halo graphic novel breaking quarantine
want to know why sergeant johnson didn't
die in the first game
here you go
halo graphic novel the last voyage of
the infinite score it's the last voyage
of the infinite score because everyone
dies because
of course they do everyone dies life is
irrelevant we're all
irrelevant first strike in a rare moment
of beauty mastery finds that his friends
blue team actually survived reach
because
apparently
spartans are the only ones important
enough to live halographic novel armor
testing
master chiefs armor gets tested oh look
ooh master chief gets to have his armor
tested huh oh how important is he is a
great storyline what do you want from me
huh what do you want from me what does
it even matter why do we even met her
home and gore only facts matter emotions
only distract
halographic novel second sunrise over
humavasa a journalist tries for the
journalist tries to forgive his
questions journalist tries to provide
the covenant invasion of earth and
humavasa he fails halo goes to onyx i
have not read this book in several years
let me reread it
finish
spartan threes and dr halsey discover a
foreigner shield world where they remain
trapped halo uprising massachusetts
kills aliens in space before halo 3. hey
the landfall so moody st finds some
comments it's actually pretty cool
grasslands the thursday war mortal
dictator special obscure killer five
rust after baltimore discord among
several remaining factions as well as
stopping and instructions
sorry um everyone i feel like i blacked
out for a few minutes there um
oh didn't realize we had filled this
much of the timeline out um
i guess we'll uh we'll keep going
initiation the origin story of sarah
palmer and the spartan fours basically
highly trained somewhat augmented but
not as augmented as the master chief
super soldiers
shadow of intent one of the prophets has
found a midi halo because
that's a thing apparently and he tries
to use it to reignite the covenant war
but half jaw the arbiter's front enemy
from halo 2 stops him halo last light a
halo murr mystery
turns out there's a serial killer on the
human planet of goa and detective beta
lupus is on the case and
um detectives lupus is on the case
i'm sorry uh apologies everyone i'm
getting a call from my sister one sec
oh hey sis hey uh yeah no no i'm doing
good i'm doing good um how are you
uh yeah no i just um how are things i i
would love to hear how you're
oh um no uh yeah no the um
the number is uh
752-861-3473 no it's fine um but yeah do
you haven't i would love to catch up if
you have a second but um
um no um no that that totally makes
sense i mean i'm i'm in the middle of
something important too so it's really
cool important stuff so no worries um i
guess we'll we'll talk later
yeah no it'll be it'll be fine um i
guess i love
um
uh love you yeah i know i love you i'll
i'll talk to you later
okay then uh bye
um
uh sorry about that uh
where were we
halo retribution uh veda investigates a
conspiracy to provoke another human and
covenant war with an evil bioweapon
because because yeah of course that that
happens
halo lone wolf lone wolf
spartan linda off by herself uh stopping
an evil scientist from killing a bunch
of people
all by herself because you don't need
other people in your life ever to care
about you
it's fine
hunters in the dark the saint healy and
human militaries form their first joint
task force to work together and stop
mysterious creatures from attacking the
ark and it turns out to be a rogue ai
trying to stop the halos and the groups
bond together and and work together
bonding
i miss bonding
new blood nathan fillion becomes a
spartan iv but is suddenly but
inevitably betrayed by alan tudyk's
mickey and then the rookie dies
because friends and family only
leave and betray you
halo nightfall
some dude named lock i don't know who
cares
legends origins cortana reads bedtime
stories to master chief while he sleeps
because she cares about him tales from
slipspace hunting party a team of
spartan tries to kill atriox and in the
words of tenacious d they failed
saints testimony remember the ai who
helped team black well she goes on trial
for her rights kind of like data and
that one episode of star trek the next
generation is commander data
intelligence yes they're from that
university had a friend in picard to
help him so
cool rise of atriox atriox rises because
he's a
cold
uncaring monkey
who survives because he realizes he
he doesn't need friends
legacy of onyx an orphan of the covenant
war is re-traumatized when a covenant
sec attacks her new family but she
survives because she doesn't need them
she doesn't need family to survive smoke
and shadow rion forge the daughter of
the lead spartan of the spirit of fire
works as a smuggler because she didn't
need her father in her life she found
her own way she didn't need family she
finally got on just fine
renegades and point of light rion finds
the remnants of the ai 343 guilty spark
who used to be chakas but now is just a
cold uncaring ai and they work together
to find 343's lost humanity and then
they realized at the end that the true
great journey was the friends that you
don't murder along the way
friends
like uh like i have friends right you're
my friends all of you out there watching
this
or are you just here for the lore
i make all these jokes and funny bits
but you just want all of this don't you
you just want information just plugged
into your brains is that what you want
just the information only the
information i can give you to give the
information
all i am is information tails from slip
space knight takes bishop a spartan 3
assassinates a covenant from halo 4.
tales from slip space fire to majestic
poker night the spartan fire team
majestic plays poker escalation sarah
palmer goes after dr halsey hunt the
truth keegan michael key gets caught up
in a cover-up of the spartan two
programs child soldiers tails from slip
space on the brink master chief fights
with the blue team to defeat yet another
covenant splinter group tales from
suspects dominion splinter the story of
how cortana survived halo 4 and was
saved by foreign technology to control
all the guardians to eventually destroy
the galaxy because her friends failed to
see her in her hour of need she's only
viewing her as a vehicle for knowledge
i'm not the wonderful person that he is
[Music]
i
i feel so alone
i feel as lonely as spartan grey team
and envoy who woke up after six years to
find the covenant ward pass them by
left out a date without anything normal
left or like buck in bad blood who is
forced to work on one more mission with
his old friend mickey who betrayed him
or in shadows of reach where master
chief must return to reach to find the
tech to kill his best friend cortana
in the end i'm just like the crew
entails from slipspace undefeated lost
in space trying desperately to survive
but with no hope because
that's it
that's the end i have no more knowledge
left to give that's every piece of halo
media ever what do i have to show for it
anyways a board full of books and novels
and
no one here just the funyuns to keep me
company
i just consumed them all and yet i feel
so alone i tried to down them so quickly
to get out the information yet i forgot
to enjoy them along the way i
i can't i can't stay here i can't do
this
[Music]
we don't find you
we
get on the train
of this
[Music]
[Applause]
all i place left of him
wow
i'm sorry about
all of that i i
i just got so
so caught up in categorizing and
describing all the pieces of halo lore
that i
forgot
the stories
behind it
the tales of heroism and cowardice
of of life
i just re-listened to sadie's story the
optional audio log from halo odst the
one about a young girl escaping the
nightmare of new mombasa falling to the
covenant during halo 2. her story was
one of thousands that we could have
followed during that horrible event each
person with their own harrowing and
terrifying story
and yet none of them made it up on this
board in this huge galactic battle of
soap operas and alien wars and battles
and things going all the way back to
10000 bc and yet
sadie's story
was just as emotionally moving as any of
them a completely optional miscible side
quest
matters to me
just as much
as all of this
it affected me just as much as the
fights of fire team raven
in their adrenaline pumping fun and
enjoyment even though they all died in a
glorious beautiful recording costing
battle timelines and lore are wonderful
ways to enjoy our media i love delving
into lore just as much as the next
person perhaps even more getting ready
to dive into the next game
but i think it's important not to forget
that these stories are meant to move us
and that knowing every piece of
backstory isn't just one way to enjoy a
work of art
these people
become
family our friends and we share them
with others
it's how we connect to each other and
teach ourselves about humanity that's
what stories are not just information
and we should always make sure to take
the time to feel the story being told
instead of just getting the information
just the facts
because that's what good stories do
affect us and that's what halo has
always done bring us together in an
online campaign or multiplayer to shoot
noobs in the face
and i think about that now more than
ever
and that is why i'm not going to explain
the last book divine light
so that you
can discover it for yourself and
so i can and be moved by it and i'll see
you all in halo infinite because halo
is my family
that's healthy right
yeah
yeah it is
[Music]
hmm
hey there everyone uh i hope you enjoyed
the weirdness that was this video um as
should be obvious this video was very
much inspired by the works of folks like
brian david gilbert over at polygon or
formerly of polygon as well as people
like quinton reviews here on youtube so
i just want to give a shout out to those
folks for clearly being a big influence
on what this video became and actually
with that being said as should be
obvious this video was very much an
experiment uh not only for myself as a
content creator trying to do something
new and weird and strange and fun uh
with the normal typical video format
that we do here at gamespot but also an
experiment for gamespot as a whole so
with that being said i am particular but
all of us here would really love to hear
your thoughts and feedback and reactions
to this video did you like it going
strange and over the top uh we really
would just love to hear your thoughts so
please let us know down in the comments
below we'll certainly be reading them
and i'm i'm very excited but at the end
of the day i really just hope you had
fun with this video this is definitely a
passion project for me and if you want
to see more of myself as well as the
rest of us here at gamespot don't forget
to subscribe and check out some of our
other videos like our halo timeline or
everything you need to know for halo
infinite but beyond all that i just hope
that you as always live long and prosper